what's included in the four minutes or
so of new footage added to Spider Man
far from home join us as we break down
what's new for the rerelease why it
might have been excluded from the
original cut of the film and whether you
ought to make another trip to the
theater for it as Peter in neder leaving
school after finishing up their classes
for the year
Peter rattles off a list of things he
has to get done before the students
leave on their European trip first on
his list pick up his passport from the
post office when Peter gets there he
finds himself at the end of a
ridiculously long line which isn't
moving at all anxious to move on to the
rest of his tasks Peter unleashes a
small spider shaped drone from his
backpack which sneaks behind a counter
and opens up another passport pickup
line which had been closed so that the
postal worker behind the glass could eat
lunch it's not really necessary to
understand the rest of the film but it's
a clever little bit of foreshadowing he
needs a passport to travel abroad and
his use of a drone is a small-scale
version of how Quentin Beck will later
use drones for his master plan as part
of his plan to woo MJ in Europe Peter
wants to buy her a glass black dahlia
necklace and Venice after which he'll
give it to her at the top of the Eiffel
Tower the only problem is he doesn't
actually have enough money to get the
necklace so he says goodbye to a few
prized possessions in pursuit of some
quick cash Peter heads to a pawn shop
carrying a box of superhero action
figures don't the collectible action
figures and they're worth more than your
car although the camera only lingers on
the box for a second making it difficult
to tell exactly which characters it
contains there is one that Peter decides
at the last second not to pon plugging
what appears to be a mostly yellow
figure from the box Peter tells the
pawnshop owner that he's decided to keep
the robot after all this could be a nod
to Peter's deep attachment to Tony Stark
a man who essentially dressed as a robot
or it could be someone we've never seen
before if Sony and Marvel have really
parted ways for future Spidey films it's
questionable whether any of the seed
planning and far from home will ever
come to fruition this one likewise isn't
necessary to the plot but it is a nice
tip of the symbolic hat to the fact that
far from home marks the end of Phase
three of the MCU and a changing of the
superhero guard next Peter stops at his
local bodega where he purchases the dual
headphone
chapter that is so crucial to his
romantic goals after Peter makes a
valiant but terrible attempt to
communicate what he's looking for in
Spanish the bodega owner corrects him
and sells him the adapter telling Peter
he needs to work on his Spanglish of
course
Peter's plan for the dual headphone
adapter to use it to watch movies on the
plane with MJ goes tragically sideways
and he winds up sitting next to his
teacher mr. Harrington instead while MJ
and Peter's rival Brad watch movies
using the dual adapter that Brad also
happened to have with him the bodega
scene was probably cut for a reason but
it does drive home just how much effort
he put into getting all the pieces of
his plan to win over MJ right finally
just before leaving the country Peter
takes down a local organized crime
syndicate operating out of an Italian
restaurant wearing the iron spider suit
that Tony gave him an Avengers infinity
war
Peter handily dispatches a roomful of
baddies while delivering a barrage of
quips about one-star yelp reviews and
stingy tips the police complement Peter
on his new suit realizing it's obviously
stark tech you go man next Amanda well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs I'm kidding I'm kidding it's
one of many reminders we get in far from
home that Peter is still grieving the
loss of Tony a mental state that Beck
takes full advantage of it's a fun
Spidey action sequence but given that
there's no shortage of action and Tony
Stark reminders and far from home it's
easy to understand why it didn't make
the final cut
after Mysterio assumes he has killed
spider-man he turns his sights to the
other loose threads on his plan Ned MJ
and Betty he decides to stage a massive
attack in London in which Mysterio will
save the city from an Avengers level
threat but not before there are
extensive civilian casualties Peter's
friends included that gathers a group of
his accomplices together in a parking
garage and reminds them to make sure to
take plenty of video and upload it to
the internet since all the civilians who
would normally be posting to social
media will be dead after all if Mysterio
was going to be the next Iron Man he's
going to have to go viral he then takes
a call from Nick Fury who informs him of
an elemental threat in London which of
course Beck planned the scene ends with
Beck ending the call and repeating his
earlier line never apologized for being
the smartest person in the room while
this scene death
we drives home just how far Beck is
willing to go for the sake of his plan
it pushes him a little too far into
cartoonish mustache twirling territory
with his casual talk of dead innocence
and a catch braves at the end while the
scenes added to the spider-man far from
home re-release mostly consists of fun
Spidey stuff none of it really enhances
the plot or the characters in any
meaningful way it's all pretty
superfluous and in the case of the
Mysterio scene may actually work to the
film's detriment the Peter centric
scenes are entertaining and the
restaurant fight is a great opportunity
to see the iron spider suit in action
one last time whether it's worth a
return to the theater it depends on how
much you liked far from home to begin
with since it's basically the same movie
if you kind of wanted to see it again
anyway or if you haven't managed to see
it for the first time it's a good excuse
to finally go check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]